I'm finally convinced that it's probably
not happening the alternate fighter
ratings are so low Connor Lily dungeon
yeah like human Wonder Boy Thompson he
went there on the last episode to help
him Coach he's like are you actually
gonna coach today and he's like yeah
I'll be in there you can tell he's just
like hey man he's my face I'm not here
I'm here to party in Vegas and do my
thing and again his guy gets annihilated
they're 0-3 the top two news events you
brought you this is where we're at right
now in MMA Mark Zuckerberg's Elon Musk
is it gonna happen is it a gimmick fight
Conor McGregor misses the usada not
fighting this year boom that's where
we're at